My flesh is trembling, my
sound is faint,
ce Ru -
1 house, oh, it's
amazing,
I'm so blunt, I'm Subaru, I'm going
through it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
, why are you living for bothering Emilia-sama, who's supposed to help
you?  I've always been helped by Subaru, so
there's a part of me
that's taken aback by showing me how weak I'm in slipping like this, Emilia.
Because I want you to look at
me.I want you to forget that I'm really a weak, pitiful, hopeless
guy.I won't hate Subaru just by showing him a little more weakness
.
The stubborn magic erased the latter is
not persuasive.  I'm relieved to have returned safely. It's
polite to be an idiot that the gargran fruit won't fall off in the wind.